good afternoon we are now live
good afternoon my name is Vincent
Garnier I'm the director chairman of the
ftth council welcome to this webinar uh
part of our webinar series I will ask a
little bit of patience we are still
welcoming many guests so we'll probably
give them an extra minute before we kick
off the
so I'll come back to you in a few
seconds
foreign
we still have
quite a few guests in the process of
joining the call maybe we should start
with the first Slide the the webinars
title digitizing fiber deployments
discussing ftth Trends and best
practices it is sponsored by site
tracker a member of the ftth council and
Amerigo garofano is with me and I will
introduce him a bit further after a
short introduction I will now walk you
through America if you could move to the
next slide please so a few words uh for
those who don't already know the ftth
council we are an industry Association
we are non-for-profit our mission is to
promote the deployment and take care of
full fiber Network throughout Europe
um our membership is around 150 160
members who represents vendor operator
investor the entire value chain of the
ftth industry
I'm gonna go next slide
um and we as part of our communication
and our uh objective to educate the the
overall ecosystem around
fiber networks we are conducting a
series of webinars which are dedicated
to exploring all angles of ftth
deployments you can see the theory on
our website you can register to the new
webinar
and we we welcome any comments about any
subject you would like to us to treat in
the future
the next slide
so the session practically is recorded
replay will be made available to you
after the session you can forward that
to whoever you want in your organization
um having registered to this webinar and
given your consent you will receive
future communication about our next
events
now you can
ask question not verbally but you can
use the question box that you should see
on the control panel of the platform do
not hesitate to ask questions if we have
time I will convey them to Amerigo our
speaker at the end of the presentation
if we don't have time to cover every
question we will forward this question
with your detail to our speaker today
and I have no doubt that they will be
addressed after the webinar so don't
expect to ask questions we want this to
be as interactive as possible
next slide
and before I give the flow to our
speaker uh we thought it could be
interesting to give you an overview
about where the ftth rollout stands it's
going to be very great just to set the
scene and transition them to the
presentation on the topic of today
the ftth coverage has really
threshold of 50 in Europe of course the
situation varies greatly between uh
between country as you can see on the
map but on average which we will pass
the 50 bar which means that one
household in two has potentially access
to fiber it doesn't mean that
that number of households is effectively
connected to Internet service provider
using fiber and that difference is what
we call the tech-up and we see that on
the next slide
which shows the percentage of the
population of the household effectively
using internet running on profile
networks and you see that that number is
much lower it's around 25 27 on average
and that reflects the fact that only 50
percent of
um household having potentially and
technically access to fiber are
effectively subscribing to fiber so
there's still no way to go in Europe to
have the entire population
maximizing the benefits that is brought
by final Networks
next slide
now when we look at who is running out
fiber and we take the picture based on
our latest survey which is uh dated
based on on data from from the end of
21. the new survey by the way will be
published at the conference in Madrid in
April this year and it will be based on
the data
based on at the end of 22. but as we see
today you see that 39 of the home paths
are passed by incumbent operators
whereas 57 is due to initiative from
alternative service provider
the the market has really started with
um alternative operator incumbent in
most places have reacted with some delay
we see now a rebalancing of things but
clearly the the market of uh fixed line
using fiber has and the development of
fiber has been has been the opportunity
to totally change the landscape and what
we see now in terms of Market that is
the presence of a large variety of
Market players of operators many of them
are open access sometimes wholesale what
you see on the right side of the screen
is a description of different type of
business model we have analyzed and it's
it's extracted from a report you can
find on our website but you see that
many of these business model involve a
proportion of wholesale or Open Access
so the situation has become much more
complex in term of organizing the
management of the network and I guess
this is maybe something that we will
touch on a bit later in the presentation
and my last introduction slide America
concerned the future
um we are very optimistic in the growth
ahead of us
um we are as we said at 50 in terms of
one pass 28 for subscriber we are gonna
really significantly increase those
number by 2027. uh but there's still a
long road to go there nothing is is
granted
um but we think that public policy
regulation environments investment are
all going in the right direction and
there is a big Market uh ahead of us
specifically in selected number of
countries if we move to the next slide
one of the key takeaway we see for for
the years ahead is that 60 of the growth
when it comes to potential new homes to
be connected to Fiverr will be found in
Germany UK or Italy
it doesn't mean that there is no
potential for growth in other countries
but there are smaller Belgium Greece but
if you look at Western Europe with a
wide lens 60 of Market potential for
future development of fiber are in these
three countries
key element is the need for higher
ticket or projections show that take up
will only be 60 by 27.
um we we want if if we want really to to
get the return on the investment on
fiber we need to increase Tech up to a
much higher level to make sure that
every single fiber which is put in the
ground
gets paid back with actual subscription
so that's very important in-home
connectivity is part of the equation
because if you bring one gigabit or 10
gigabit to the doorstep of a user what
you want to make sure is that the
experience in home and therefore in-home
connectivity Wi-Fi
delivers at the same level of bandwidth
and here there is still a battle to be
yet before because it's not always the
case and sometimes you know home
connectivity can be a bottleneck
remote coverage is key
um we were saying that 50 of the
coverage concerns on average
um Europe but if you look at rural area
low density area that percentage goes
down to 30 so to close the gap between
50 and 100 Key Parts will be on low
density areas
copper switch shock is also a major and
I'll finish there copper switch office
is a major
um
elements for public policy with an
important role of regulator and
incumbent there is no sense to manage in
parallel fiber and copper it costs a lot
it's in terms of sustainability it's
it's uh it's not the right thing to do
so but it's complex move to
um to really decommission a legacy
copper Network and that requires
planning preparation and a collective
approach of the question
there are many many other challenges
ahead of us but I don't want to hijack
too much of the time for this
presentation
and I will introduce our main speaker
and the topic of today
so Amerigo garafano works with side
tracker as vice president Telecom for
emea Europe Middle East Africa what I'm
expecting you to to take away from this
session is to better understand how to
manage macroeconomic challenges identify
opportunity in the planning engineering
and construction workflow overall best
practices for digitized work processes
and what could be industry priority for
2023 or personal Excellence is clearly
very important for any stakeholder in
our industry and I think America can
bring Insight on what sort of solutions
I tracker can bring to improve every
single
stakeholder in in the in the value chain
to improve performance from an
operational perspective and I think that
leads to your part in America thank you
very much
thank you so much Vincent uh good
morning good afternoon to everyone
um
I'm very pleased and honored to be part
of this webinar in collaboration with
ftth Council and before we go through it
I start with a wish to see you and many
of the people on on the call at the
upcoming ftth event in Madrid that the
Council of Europe is organizing so
looking forward to to have a
face-to-face meetings and nice
discussions however today the scope of
um my presentation is it's a way to
share experience of our company side
tracker in the field of fiber the
deployments that we have had so far and
they will be very much Focus about the
collaborative collaboration and
digitalization
and hopefully I will bring in
um some of the best practice with the
humble approach from our experience of
having worked with a number of ftth
companies both in the US and in Europe
so far as well as some of them are also
in Asia Pacific
so I need to take a uh one minute just
to introduce our company for the ones
who don't know about us
um hi tracker is a a software
cloud-based solution developed around 10
years ago initially for the mobile
deployment networks of us enabling them
to
um
manage and cope with the very fast
deployments of what that was the 4G
network at that time
um
our solution over time has then
evolved and been adopted by at the
moment more than 200 customers around
the world and the number of users that
are connected to our platform at the
moment are more than 50 000.
and the company has grown over the over
the years initially obviously started in
us but our presence in Europe has now
becoming stronger and stronger since
about four or five years now and we are
gaining customers
um who are typical customers of site
tracker in the Telecom industry
primarily service providers so mnos who
are at the moment facing the challenges
of the 5G deployment
fiber to the home
service providers in the model that was
presented before by one Sons they were
both incumbent and the alternative
operators as well as we see some of them
being some sort of regional
service providers
then in the fiber business of course we
we also work with the service
contractors
who are building this network because in
some way we we provide a solution both
to the service providers who need to
plan and deploy their network but also
to the ones that they've been assigned
the contractor work to build these
networks and we'll talk later on about
synergies and potential benefits of
collaboration when having side tracker
on both sides of the of the process
just to continue our company is um
Venture capital-backed type of company
has had big names like Salesforce energy
Ventures Dodge Telecom Capital Partners
lately in the last round we read also
entity docomo we have some companies in
the energy sector who are also financing
our growth because as a matter of fact
we are
um
let's say redeploying the same model and
concept also to some sector of the
energy
um business for example typical EV
charging
but because the scope of our
conversation today is about fiber
deployment
I will focus very much on that
um
the introduction we already had thanks
also to ftth council
um as I said before we will focus the
presentation on two main topics enabling
digital workflows what does it mean
um and also the collaborative
collaboration and standardization
aspects and then hopefully we will end
with with some Q A's uh at the end
in order to make this session
interactive we have organized uh with
the ftth some interesting polls
which you are kindly invited to respond
and we will base our discussion also on
the response that we will see so
please do not do not hesitate to start
to fill in your your answers here
I'm bringing the
no questions live so what are your top
challenges today Labor and Staffing
material Logistics collecting field
Cruise managing data so I see that we
we're starting to together
uh response
um quite a few so we give you another
15 seconds to to cast your vote uh I can
already tell you that one is really
um standing out for the time being we
have quite a nice percentage of the
audience uh having built it I think uh
I will close that within uh five or ten
seconds so you still have time to to
vote
but we we are
finding uh um now I think a confirmation
of the initial Trends so I'll I'll close
now in the interest of time and I'll
share the result with you so as you can
see uh the first labor and Staffing uh
is is receiving 45 approximately half of
the votes number two is managing data as
a key Challenge and then once close uh
the two other options
material logistic and connecting field
crew maybe
um your comment on that um
yes
um first of all very interesting
um in some way confirming what we have
heard also in other kind of forums
um
there is a a lack of resources
specialized resources to sustain the
growth of ftth deployments in Europe
um the pandemic has definitely brought
us a new a new reality a new ways of
working which we are all now adopted to
to to use and in order to be efficient
with this uh with a working that include
remote collaboration remote working and
so on you need you need the reliable
connections at home the in-house
connectivity that vansanta was saying
before is very very much important so
first is to pass the fiber through to
the to the buildings then to connect and
then to make sure uh so in order to do
all these works there is a need of of
you know Manpower and this is definitely
a point that we recognize uh the second
point if I remember well was um about
um managing the data and this is also
another another important aspect that we
we recognize and hopefully we will also
touch with ours with our presentation
today uh let's say these two main
drivers that means
uh how we can address
lack of resources second how do we
manage the
uh
what was it the second one the
like the the complexity of data yeah the
managing the managing data yes of course
and the third one is the collaboration
aspects you know how to connect with the
crews because the reality is that yes
there is a lot of remote ways of working
but it is also physical work that is
done out there so having said that I
will take the opportunity and continue
uh introducing the concept of enabling
digital workflows this is our company
mission statement I mean
we aim to help deploying
tomorrows which is today's
infrastructure faster so that people
everywhere can experience digital equity
and a more sustainable future
summarizing basically all the things we
have said so far
connectivity and the high speed is very
much important so
we we aim to be
um you know to provide you with tools
that um will make everything faster from
the point of view of deployment that
will give faster return on the
Investments and therefore having also a
profitable growth
and at the same time we realize the
importance of partnership in the
ecosystem and we aim to be let's say in
an important um uh stakeholder and
player uh enabling all parties to be
successful
digital transformation has been let's
say a very trendy definition for for the
last five ten years and this has taken
very different shapes I'm sure that all
of you have have gone through some sort
of an internal the digital
transformation project in your company
and most likely you are still going
through it but what is important is that
when technology impacts the success of
your companies when you have the right
visibility across the projects and the
systems
um the tools that are put in place they
need to enable you to have a control of
the costs and the quality of data as
well because sometimes we many times we
realize that data quality is an issue in
many large companies
um we always need to improve ourselves
and therefore we need to
equip ourselves with the smart tools for
forecasting both the workforce but also
the revenues and and the money flow in
the company
and last but not least is a
assets are deployed to return their
investments into profits and therefore
the the agility to manage the assets is
becoming very very important
so
after let's say a first decade of
digital transformation hype what is your
definition of digitizing the process and
here thanks to Vincent we have the
second poll
yeah I think the the option you you
offer to the audience are four so a
using digital communication tool like
email or texting be updating shared
documents by spreadsheets
the third option is real-time updates to
a single data source via cloud-based
headstone
and finally uh you can choose to
complete Automation and elimination of
all paperwork
so that that's the um these are the the
two options
um
which would uh relate to digitizing a
process
um and thanks for all participants uh
who are voting I think we are more than
half of the
the attendees are now voted I give them
an extra 10 seconds
but we're not surprisingly we will see
that it's uh
overwhelmingly people are choosing
between two options I think
let me give them a couple of
seconds
right it will not change greatly so I
close and share
and you can see that you know it's it's
uh split evenly between the last two
options I might go a real time update to
single Source via cloud-based and so
forth and complete Automation and
elimination of all paperwork
um hardly no voting favor on the first
two
great thank you again
um well this this selection of course
shows a high degree of maturity of the
market and yourself for representing it
in understanding that adopting digital
transformation is not just you know
working with the basics of the tools
that I would say still we found in the
market in many
service providers or companies that are
maybe of small medium size
um we we we often find
um Excel and emails uh and the values
the documents sharing
um
platforms to be the current ways of
working and definitely
um your response to this poll
demonstrate that either you're using it
and therefore you are enjoying the
benefits of
digitalization through digitalization or
that you are aiming to get to that point
but you definitely recognize which is
the path
towards there so moving ahead and
starting to give some
um we need to move the slide sorry for
that
Yeah so basically this is a the hard
life of of an employee who is struggling
with today's ways of working
um where there are minor spreadsheets as
complicated there can be many times we
have seen that um
you know they are they are a blocker to
data quality
um
I've heard that the experience of some
Tower companies I know it's the same
sector but not exactly like fiber
deployment who have acquired assets
through an Excel file received from the
other company and you know it was a
really a struggle for them to understand
what kind of assets they were acquiring
um
that means doesn't give visibility you
don't know where you need to focus uh
sometimes you don't know your assets if
you can deliver a new service or if you
are owning the assets you want to occupy
for example you want to lease your extra
capacity to some other service providers
so digital Asset Management has become a
very important element in in our
industry
and therefore
um
to start to bring some sort of
definition at least from our own
perspective
it is very important to templatize the
workflows so making an effort the
Gathering regardless of the tool that
you will adopt for digitalization of the
workflow it is most important try to
remove the exceptions because exceptions
will not enable you to standardize the
process
there has to be a way that things need
to be managed remotely because otherwise
it's going to be very
um costly if um
supervisor need to be always on site
where there is the the construction
place the construction site and
therefore the concept of having ability
to remote
control what the others are doing it's
it's a fundamental and at the same time
there has to be a flexible configuration
which enables to
um for example having different formats
for um different kinds of of site works
optimizing the process the number two is
all about uh automating workflows so uh
input of data Gathering
um results and in some way
um avoid the human intervention improves
the quality and of course reduce uh
reduce time
um site tracker value to talk about our
own experience is definitely manage high
volume of projects and assets so trying
to standardize as we said before and as
much as possible try to adopt this kind
of techniques to
um projects that have a I don't know
kilometers of fibers to be deployed or
base stations in case of mobile networks
or towers and so on so whatever kind of
large volume of install base you you
have you get more benefits by automating
and standardizing their workflows
um data have to be quickly entered and
I'm not talking about just you know text
but I'm thinking also about pictures and
videos and therefore
here I'm bringing also the concept of
the mobility so having tools that are
seamlessly working with desktop
application so that whatever it is
captured on site for example is
automatically uploaded to the cloud and
immediately made available and be part
of the asset information in therefore
removing a sending of large files of
video with videos and and pictures or
documents in case you know a contract is
assigned to to execute some Road works
for example
um the third element is going into the
direction that was highlighted before
that means managing data complexity on
the first poll there was this question
um so data have to be quickly available
always and they've to be analyzed
because analyzing the data will enable
smarter
um forecasts and prediction of future
events
um as well as data have to be in real
time so that there is no ambiguity of
the data that we find in the system we
need to be sure that whatever we insert
in the system is visible at the other
end and vice versa
because Data Drive decision
here I'm bringing up the case of three
um
Fiber customer success success stories
uh where basically the first one was
struggling with um project financing and
um and not so well coordinated the
permitting structure
um work permit of course and thanks to
the the modules that Setra brought in in
the finance module and the intelligent
project templates and trackers we
enabled in this specific case to reduce
32 percent the turnaround time of
Enterprise projects in the second case
um in some way there was some sort of
lack of visibility of the goals and
revenues
while you know the ambition of the
company were quite High
um there with the help of um side
tracker documentation generation and
mobile uh the mobile device uh
seamlessly connected to the to the
platform and the services that site
tracker provided and summarized they
were giving four hours of savings per
project during closeout so
at the time of closing the project you
know they were four hours less of
activity done compared to the before
situation and the last case is was
difficult to forecast projects so with
the intelligence and analytics that we
brought in
um
it was taking 104 days to go live with
the
one and a half thousand
users so in some way these are some
examples uh all of them in um in in
North America where we have seen that we
stepped into a reality which were facing
some problems and then
thanks to the values modules of our
digitized workflows uh we're able to
have different kind of savings from
operational time and cost savings
the next poll number three will focus on
the current level of digitalization
today so they moved one step too much
here it is so with the support of
Vincent we will see the third poll
yeah and that one is very
straightforward question you know what
is the percentage of the process that
you considered as being digitized today
is it more than 75 which will please
America very much I know uh 50 25 or
less than 10 I hope you're not in that
category
um and I see that some of you are in
that category actually which is uh maybe
a good opportunity for uh our presenter
today
um let's see how people are voting uh we
have
more than 30 of you having already
completed your your vote
um
again I see some Trends
um shipping out it's quite balance more
balanced than the for the other pops
actually
um let's give
a few additional seconds to for the
trends to to be more
to materialize better
um yeah I think we're getting stable I'm
gonna share the results with all of you
um so
the winner is the in the middle fifty
percent uh but 40 of the audience uh the
interesting thing I think personally is
that 65
are above 50 in their process
um which I don't know I'll let you
comment America
well first of all we are all happy when
things are going to the right direction
man if I go back to your previous slides
um
you know we all aim to have a 100 uh
home past
uh and connected uh users but not
everybody's there and there are always
reasons why for example there are some
companies who unfortunately have not yet
enjoyed and they're on the low scale of
these um of these percentages they've
not yet enjoyed the full benefits of
digitalization uh
I would say democratically we don't mind
we will be able to support both those
ones that are really
um Advanced because they are uh you know
would say 50 75 in some way it is a
level of of progress and maturity or
digitalization but everybody needs to be
there at certain point and it goes end
to end with the deployment of new
infrastructure then who knows when the
infrastructure in fixed and mobile I
would add as well will be there what
kind of new needs will come up when
everybody will be connected with the
ultra fast internet connectivity
and everything will be cloud-based and
digitalized I'm sure the future will
have something else for us to to improve
when the to give us a new opportunity
so having said that I would like to
continue and become a little bit maybe
find memory go just take this
opportunity we are halfway through the
uh the session so if you have any
questions don't hesitate you know next
to the box where we have where you you
casted your your poll vote there is a
question box use it we will uh address
your question as I said uh after the
call at the end of the call or pass it
on to America for for follow-up
um so just a reminder to everyone
yeah thank you so much so
um
we enter now into the part of my
presentation where I will talk more
about collaboration the first part as I
reminded you was about digitalization of
workflows second one was about
collaboration because we all realized
how important it is in our industry and
generally in any kind of industry to
have a very good collaboration here we
are showing something which is not
really connected apparently visually to
our business because it's construction
of buildings but in reality there are a
lot of similarities and that are in the
Telecom business where we need to build
the networks digging in the road and
connecting uh fiber slicing and do
everything that is needed to bring the
final service to the customer
having said that what what what is
important here is that the connected
construction that means when people
start to to collaborate with each other
helps controlling the cost
um and to schedule the variances and
ensures that the time the projects are
uh completed in time through different
sites this is a generic definition comes
from the from the construction in
industry but if we try to apply it a
little bit more to to our reality and
also what side tracker aims to to
deliver
the use case for us for the
collaboration are you know assigning
um
work views to uh to teams you know be
able to to decide that a certain team
needs to go on to uh to a site where the
the fiber Network needs to be progressed
in this in its deployment sometimes we
may need the certificates of people
performing certain activities
we need to collect documents pyramids so
definitely managing this into a single
repository available at any time by
anyone who is authorized definitely
improves the collaboration makes it
faster and most important removes the
the potential mistakes that are in the
system
um if you are if let's say if you are a
customer and you use contractors
um or if you are a contractor you use a
sub subcontractors you you may want to
monitor the performance of the various
teams that are working for you and
therefore the collection of data of the
projects you are building
in the meantime may help you to create
the knowledge for the future
and then communication with
um
messaging an email into a single place
it avoids that in order for you to
communicate with another
member of this community of contractors
it makes you to get out of the system of
the application and then you need to
send an email from your own system
with such tracker you will have
everything integrated and therefore
while you are working in the tool for
the specific site which is experiencing
a project change everything happens in
the system
so now
I will say a little bit more some
concept about the process optimization
techniques so first of all it's very
important to Define milestones and
Associate them to uh what are the
paypoints the that means when is the
time also to let's say to pay or to get
paid if you are a contractor you would
like to be paid as soon as possible and
therefore you would like to make sure
that your customer has a complete
invisible
um
view of what you have delivered for that
project
um are there cycle uh so can you
standardize uh also
um the the various Milestones into a
project what needs to be standardized
and what we localized because definitely
there are some activities that needs to
reflect the local regulation or local
reality in a certain region or Province
or whatever others instead they should
be managed as much as possible at it's a
national level or let's say standard
level so to say
setting expectation that means making a
clear roadmap of measurable object
objectives
um our tool in some way
pushes you to think like that so that it
is very clear also to come up with with
kpis that can be measured and they can
be discussed because then data will be
reported at the team level and everybody
has a unique version of the truth
assign accountability that means make
sure that for every activity there is
the right person who is supposed to
execute the task in that project and
therefore can be accountable and can be
traced what he or she has been doing on
that activity
all these go back to the single source
of or truth
um which is
removing all the chances of making
mistakes or let's say spending time to
find information which are which are
already there
here is the same concept a little bit
more into details from you know left
side you could see that yes apparently
we are all BC we all have uh we are all
productive producing something
um we have spreadsheets we create
reports we spend a lot of time and we we
feel are very very busy but most of the
time we are not working at the best
because
we have not standardized our activities
we have not standardized templatized our
workflow the collaboration is in some
way limited only to the to those people
who are working with each other is very
difficult for example to extend the
collaboration in a sort of community
where team members can talk and share
information regardless of the specific
project they are working with
moving on the right hand side and
templatizing
the activities and workflows and forms
um and working into a cloud that means
in a single source of Truth real-time
based enables you know to have a
real-time collaboration and consistent
reporting
another you know hint here is during
optimization phase try to identify the
dependencies uh that brings certain on
certain activities
um split templates to create a more
optimized version so don't need to
create a monster template but if you can
break it down and making more sub
templates also that is a a good way of
working and identify steps that can be
streamlined so these are let's say the
the main Logics on which our tool is a
is a designed upon
um
the other element is learning phase
again we always say we need to to learn
from what we practice and um but also
the the knowledge needs to be structured
and knowledge is about data data that
can be
um presented through simple uh
personalizable dashboards that can be
made available at different level of
reporting in the hierarchy our
dashboards can be
made them uh uh let's see available at
the regular times on a weekly basis at a
given time of the of the week
um so this cuts out all the
time spent on reporting because if the
data is there and the the reporting has
been built in the right way you just
need to press the button sometimes you
just need to schedule you don't even
have to press the button everything is
there and the report can go to all the
stakeholders in in
zero time basically no no efforts to
create status reporting but what is the
power of data and the analytics and the
AI that site tracker with the support of
Salesforce which is our the same Cloud
partner we we are enabling
um to predict the future
and give some tools to our customers our
users that enable them to
anticipate if for example in a in a
given territory there are two
contractors which are given the same
market share in the construction field
for example one can monitor the
performance of the other and understand
what can happen if it continues like
this where one is performing
much better than the other then it is
easy to simulate a scenario with all
this data and data analytics
what what could be a scenario in
remodeling the market share that have
been given to the two contractors
um so bottom line
we have at the moment more than 70 fiber
operators and contractors that are using
uh site tracker
um they have all had common challenges
in terms of a project efficiency with
the uh no program visibility data that
are either duplicated or missing or
basically driven to to bad quality and a
lot of manual reporting
our Solutions are called The Trackers
which is a sort of a very powerful Excel
like kind of layout but in reality it's
a mass is enabling Mass data changes in
one single goal and most important is
real time so whatever it is changed is
not on the single Excel file of that
person it is in the whole in the whole
system and talking about communication
and collaboration what we call the
connect portal is where we enable
uh service providers and their
contractors to work in the same
environment and have a seamless
communication about the project
execution we have seen that different
customers have given us a very good
feedback
can be Quantified above 20 22 percent
increase in the project management
efficiency time to review
your company is profitable and
generating cash
so reducing time to revenue either to
provide a new service to the homes to
the subscribers or to be paid for the
service that a contractor has given to
to a service provider it is important to
have you know a very good accuracy of
project execution and report and so
that's why our templates and schedules
projects and permits are giving us this
um this um these tools and these
capabilities together with the mobile
which is of course enables everything to
happen at the site
the last but not least having different
systems different tools most of them in
the first generation of digitalization I
would say brings inefficiency and
um having a cloud-based solution which
is at the moment uh considered sort of a
standard in the market leading
leading solution can give
I would say a very high percentage of of
saving in iot costs
so
to conclude my presentation I would like
to end with the final uh poll what are
your prioritizations for 2023
and sorry I was I forgot to unmute
myself uh four options that you you
offered to the to the audience improving
collaboration as well increase process
digitization
increasing productivity
or other options
so thanks for your participation and see
that
nearly half of the
the attendance is as voted already
it's quite balanced it's uh let's let's
give a little bit more time to see if we
have clear a clear winner
seems to
yeah I'll close now we we are getting
um
productivity uh as number one
but
um
process utilization uh is also
coming close
and improving collaboration is third
yeah
Marigold yes I'm here and I just wanted
to recognize this um
um
these results are once again
we believe that with our solution
um and the focus we have on digitizing
the workflows uh enables and increased
productivity and our current customers
are demonstrating that
they can benefit from that
um increased process digitalization and
the collaboration are also addressed by
our Solutions in particular the one
which we call connect portal where
um
as I said before directly the customer
and the vendor of the services can
collaborate in real time and therefore
avoiding a lot of
um interactions outside the system using
various tools that have proven not to be
uh fully
digitizing or fully in line with the
digitalization
time is for questions now
I don't know if you could
um because I have I mean you can still
ask questions and again use the they
appropriate
section of the the control panel for
this but I have one question which
I think it's it's all about you know
pyramids and managing the number of
Regulation you especially
these these being different region
countries
um how does um does your system can
actually helping um
operators with that America
foreign
biggest challenge is with permitting and
managing many regulation across
different local jurisdictions and and
yes yes well um you know we have
dedicated the permit
um uh modules in our in our solution
um and therefore we we recognize that
part of a project construction in
telecommunication has
um implications on pyramids
and we we enable that through to our
solution and we can we have templates
which have in some way been built around
uh lots of um markets in in Europe and
the us so we may believe that there is
already quite off the shelf uh Solutions
available but of course we can always
um
understand and Implement any something
that is a local permit
um requirement
okay
I have another question just coming
um I think it's it's relates to I mean
we struggle with uh collaboration when
it comes to working with
um you know the the entire ecosystem of
vendor contractors in the field and I
guess the question is how do we
get them to adopt uh this tool and and
to cooperate with us on the tool how do
we expand the usage of the tool to the
entire ecosystem
yes I mean we we know that um adopting
new technology is always a something
um challenging because people by Nature
are used to to keep on using what they
have
um I want to experience though is that
um thanks to the very
uh powerful user interface and the
simple concept on the way we have
designed our workflow to be digitized it
brings a lot of adoption one element
that didn't bring about the success of
our story is in the market is that 92
percent of the companies are renewing
the contract which I tractor after three
four years from the initial project and
there is in single in every single
company an average of more than 94 of
the user's adoption this is a sign that
most likely we have designed the right
tool that um it is simple to use and
provides immediate benefit to to the
users because in some way
it enables them to to fill in data they
can find whatever they have inserted the
that up to that moment and um
the same information that the input is
visible to the others so it reduces also
a lot of time reporting I think time
reporting and the quality data
improvements are the main benefits that
the user has to see in order to adopt uh
technology like this one that we are
proposing
maybe you have time for our last
question
um
this one comes from a company which says
that they're an organization with
several business units have already a
lot of technology and I.T tools and
software and
the question concretely is how do we do
do we justify it to add you know yet
another system into a really busy mix of
tool coexisting
well I would say it won't be a surprise
if the adoption of a tool like
sidetracker will enable the removal of
some others because in some way our tool
is quite uh comprehensive of the
end-to-end processes in the area of
deployment operations
um sometimes we realize that what we
bring in with side tracker is today
manage but two three different tools so
if we can perform a joint analysis with
that organization we might help them to
recognize
what tools needs to be phased out to
bring in one that brings at the same
time Innovation and
tools reduction and therefore also the
Opex of those tools will be removed
thank you very much
um I mean we're getting closer to the
end of this session I want to make sure
that people are on time for for their
Max meeting so I I think we'll probably
stop here
um maybe shall I take this opportunity
to you know to go back to to your
introduction remark which is to welcome
everyone today on the webinar to our
events in Madrid in a few weeks time on
the 18th 19th and 20th of April the ftth
conference where you you will be aware
ago I'm gonna wear a side tracker will
be presenting its solution but we we are
welcoming the entire industry for for
three day of grain inside and networking
and maybe I'll leave you the the floor
for uh the last few words your risk as I
said we play for this session so you can
share the content with your friends and
colleagues and you will be invited to
further a session of the webinar series
but I'm gonna go a few one minutes to
conclude
I will be very fast first of all
thanking you Vincent for the
collaboration and to thank also ftth
Council Europe
to host as in this webinar and I of
course thank all the attendees of this
conference of this webinar I look
forward to those ones who have asked me
questions online and I will get back
with the great pleasure and as I said
before I hope to see you all in Madrid
at the yearly event of the ftth
well thank you very much for for your
Amerigo thanks to everyone I will have
the opportunity to welcome you on any of
our event online or physical so have a
good rest of your day thanks for
spending this hour with us thank you
thank you bye-bye